So many of us, we wander through this country. We wander through our lives. We wander in darkness. Often we feel lost. Like Chris. He was doing pretty badly. Living on the street. Hair to his shoulders.
我们许多人都在这个国家流浪。我们在生活中流浪。我们在黑暗中流浪。我们常常感到迷茫。就像克里斯。他当时过得很糟。露宿街头。头发长到肩膀。
I called it the Unabomber look. I was just living in the woods. Just an open wooded area at the corner of Pond Drive and Route 347. I'd have fresh clothes on usually, but I only could do the wash every so often, and they were outside, so I smelled like the great outdoors, whether I liked that fact or not. And I very much knew I needed medical help.
我管它叫“大学炸弹客”造型。我就住在树林里。就在庞德大道和347号公路拐角处的一片开阔林地里。我通常会穿干净衣服，但我没法经常洗衣服，而且衣服是晾在外面的，所以我身上总有一股大自然的味道，不管我喜不喜欢。我非常清楚自己需要医疗救助。
So Chris needed this medical help, but of course, he had no money to pay for the medical help. He made money collecting cans and bottles on the street. Whenever he'd go to doctors or social services, he was so wacked-out looking that they wouldn't even talk to him like a person. They wouldn't even look him in the eye. It's a hell of a thing, isn't it? Wanting eye contact, not getting it. But then if you're lucky, somebody puts up the lights.
克里斯需要医疗救助，但当然，他没钱支付。他靠在街上捡罐子和瓶子挣钱。每当他去找医生或社会服务部门时，他看起来总是那么落魄，以至于人们甚至不把他当人看。他们甚至不愿正眼看他。这真是见鬼，不是吗？渴望眼神交流，却得不到。但如果你走运，有人会为你点亮灯火。
[AUDIENCE CLAPPING]
[观众鼓掌]
Welcome. WBEZ Chicago. It's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Our program today recorded on a live tour of five cities: Boston, Washington DC, Portland, Oregon, Denver, and our hometown, Chicago.
欢迎收听，芝加哥WBEZ电台。这里是《美国生活》，由国际公共广播电台发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们今天的节目是在五个城市的现场巡演中录制的：波士顿、华盛顿特区、俄勒冈州波特兰、丹佛，以及我们的家乡芝加哥。
[AUDIENCE CHEERING]
[观众欢呼]
So Chris was stuck. He needed money to go to a doctor. And then he got this idea. He remembered how a couple years before that, he had wandered off the street into a shopping mall to get warm, and there the State of New York had set up two laptop computers on a folding table.
所以克里斯陷入了困境。他需要钱去看医生。然后他想到了这个主意。他记得几年前，他曾从街上溜进一家购物中心取暖，在那里，纽约州在折叠桌上放了两台笔记本电脑。
And to see the lady just look at me, nod her head, and smile when I walked up to the booth, like I was just one of anybody, was great.
看到那位女士抬眼看我，点头微笑，就像我是一个普通人一样，那种感觉太棒了。
So he sits down at the computers, and on these two computers you could look up your name and see whether the state was holding money for you that you did not know about. And there was all sorts of money. Utility bill refunds, tax refunds, lost checks, owed to all sorts of people and institutions. Lost money. Or not even lost, since most people didn't even know it was missing. This is like money in purgatory. This is money in limbo.
他坐在电脑前，在这两台电脑上，你可以查询你的名字，看看州政府是否替你保管着你不知道的钱。钱的种类繁多。水电费退款、退税、丢失的支票，欠各种个人和机构的钱。丢失的钱。或者说甚至不算丢失，因为大多数人根本不知道这些钱不见了。这就像是在炼狱里的钱。这钱处于一种未定的状态。
And thinking about all this, Chris Sewell realized how he could pay for his doctors. He would look online, find money of theirs that they did not know about, money that the state was holding for them, and then he would present that to them.
想到这些，克里斯·塞维尔意识到他可以如何筹集看医生的钱。他可以在网上查询，找到那些他们自己都不知道的钱，那些州政府为他们保管的钱，然后把这些信息提供给他们。
Well, I was hoping that I would suddenly get a couple of phone calls and a couple of checks, and people say, "oh, wow, thanks for having done this." And then I was hoping that these doctors would just even talk to me in a civil manner. And then work my way up from there.
我当时希望我能突然接到几个电话，收到几张支票，人们会说：“哦，哇，谢谢你做了这些。”然后我希望这些医生至少能以礼貌的态度和我说话。然后从那里开始改善我的生活。
Now the crucial fact that I have to tell you about Chris Sewell at this point in the story is Chris is great at finding other people's money in these databases on the internet. And when he looked for money for the doctors at his local university hospital, not only did he find hundreds, hundreds of unclaimed Blue Cross Blue Shield checks, reimbursements, lost trust fund checks. He also found 100 checks that were owed to the hospital itself. It was a huge victory.
现在我必须告诉你关于克里斯·塞维尔的一个关键事实，那就是克里斯非常擅长在互联网的这些数据库中找到别人的钱。当他为当地大学医院的医生查找资金时，他不仅找到了数百张未领取的蓝十字蓝盾支票、报销款、丢失的信托基金支票。他还发现了100张欠医院本身的支票。这是一场巨大的胜利。
But when he went to the hospital to tell the doctors there that there was this money out there for them, he always got the same reaction.
但当他去医院告诉那里的医生有这笔钱时，他总是得到同样的反应。
There was a total wall of silence. Except for the people who were telling me to buzz off. I actually went out and I printed out the claim forms. And I had a cover letter for it. And tried, in my own humble fashion, to appear professional. I went to the Salvation Army, bought myself a blue pinstripe suit. Even with my long hair and my beard, I went around and hand-delivered all of them.
那是一堵完全沉默的墙。除了那些叫我滚开的人。我实际上专门去打印了索赔表格。我还写了一封求职信。并以我卑微的方式，尽量让自己看起来专业。我去了救世军，给自己买了一套蓝色细条纹西装。即使留着长发和胡子，我也亲自去把它们送到了。
And how did that work?
结果怎么样？
That was the one that-- it didn't work. I didn't get responses. There was no conversation. As soon as I talked, security people would just appear out of the woodwork.
那是唯一一次——没成功。我没有得到回应。根本没有对话。只要我一开口，保安就会立刻出现。
He tried letters. He tried emailing. Everybody just thought it was a scam. Eventually he got doctors to help him out through other means. And then he turned this talent elsewhere. He used it wherever and whenever he could. When his local public TV station was doing the pledge drive, he couldn't actually give money, of course, but he looked online, found $1,000 of theirs, called them up.
他试过写信。他试过发邮件。每个人都以为那是骗局。最终，他通过其他途径获得了医生的帮助。然后他把这种天赋用到了别处。他尽可能地利用它。当当地公共电视台进行募捐活动时，他当然没钱捐赠，但他上网查询，找到了他们丢失的1000美元，并打电话告诉了他们。
In setting up this interview for our radio show, he was talking to one of our producers on the phone, Julie Snyder, and while he's on the phone with her, he found $400 bucks owed to WBEZ, the radio station where we work. And using nothing more than a normal internet connection, he found $610,940 owed to the City of New York. So much money that the city comptroller honored him with an old fashioned letter of commendation. Who knew that that was a real thing, and not just something that Commissioner Gordon would give to Batman now and then?
在为我们的广播节目安排这次采访时，他正在电话里和我们的制片人朱莉·斯奈德交谈，就在和她通话时，他发现了WBEZ电台——我们工作的电台——欠下的400美元。仅仅利用普通的互联网连接，他找到了纽约市欠下的610,940美元。金额如此巨大，以至于市审计官授予他一封老式的表扬信。谁能想到这居然是真实存在的，而不只是戈登局长偶尔会发给蝙蝠侠的那种东西呢？
And a press conference. It's impossible to overstate what that meant to him, that press conference.
还有一场新闻发布会。那场发布会对他意味着什么，怎么形容都不为过。
I was extremely nervous. And there were big security lines. And I finally got there and walked into a room full of TV cameras. And I don't think I'd spoken to anybody before that in like two weeks.
我当时非常紧张。而且安保线排得很长。最后我终于到了，走进了挤满电视摄像机的房间。我想在那之前的两周里，我都没有和任何人说过话。
You hadn't spoken with anybody at all for two weeks? For two weeks you hadn't had a conversation with another person?
你已经两周没和任何人说过话了？两周没和别人交谈过？
Yeah. Again, I don't have a lot of friends where I live. I'm, you know-- trying to just reach out in the middle of a social void is very difficult. I mean, on the street, I think my record one time was I don't think I'd spoken to anybody for something like three months.
是的。再说一次，我住的地方没什么朋友。我，你知道——试图在社交空白中寻求联系是非常困难的。我是说，在街上时，我想我曾经最长的纪录是大概三个月没和任何人说过话。
And I just-- I sort of tried to put a party face and soak it all in and radiate it back as best I could.
我只是——我尽量戴上一张社交的面孔，去感受这一切，并尽我所能地回馈。
The city comptroller actually recognized me. I feel that I've somehow helped create a place for myself in society, that I'm somehow a little less lost. I'm creating a purpose for my own life, and a direction.
市审计官真的认可了我。我觉得我以某种方式帮助自己在社会中建立了一席之地，觉得自己不再那么迷茫了。我正在为自己的人生创造一个目标，一个方向。
Our program today: Lost in America. Stories of people who are lost, and how they sometimes, temporarily, if they're lucky, get found. On our program today, Sarah Vowell finds a terrorist, hiding and lost in a patriotic song. Jonathan Goldstein tries to lose something and finds that it is harder than it seems. And there is an entire magazine devoted to writing that people have lost, dropped, thrown away, and tried to destroy. Its creator reads samples on stage. Plus Jon Langford of the Mekons, the band OK Go and more. Stay with us.
我们今天的节目：《迷失在美国》。讲述人们迷失的故事，以及他们有时如何幸运地暂时被找回。在今天的节目中，萨拉·沃威尔发现了一个隐藏在爱国歌曲中、迷失的恐怖分子。乔纳森·戈尔茨坦试图丢失某样东西，却发现这比看起来要难。还有一本专门收集人们丢失、掉落、丢弃并试图销毁的文字的杂志。其创办人在现场朗读了选段。此外还有Mekons乐队的乔恩·兰福德、OK Go乐队等等。请继续收听。
[AUDIENCE CHEERING]
[观众欢呼]
Act One. Losing It.
第一幕。失去它。
Well, if you're going to do a program about people who are lost, you pretty much have to do a story about adolescence. Jonathan Goldstein is a regular contributor to our show. A quick warning before we begin, for parents listening with kids, he talks about sex in this story. Please welcome Jonathan Goldstein.
嗯，如果你要制作一个关于迷失者的节目，你几乎必须做一个关于青春期的故事。乔纳森·戈尔茨坦是我们节目的常客。在开始之前给父母们提个醒，如果带孩子听，他在这个故事里谈到了性。请欢迎乔纳森·戈尔茨坦。
[AUDIENCE CHEERING]
[观众欢呼]
Dying a virgin happened to people. Hans Christian Andersen, Queen Elizabeth the First. My grandmother's prophetically named brother, Uncle Hymen.
处男之身而死的事确实发生过。安徒生、伊丽莎白一世女王。我祖母那个名字带有预言性的兄弟，海曼叔叔。
And I knew it was the kind of thing that could happen to me. Days would turn into months, months into years, and eventually I would drop dead in a men's hotel and be buried sexless in a single cemetery plot squeezed in on my side between my parents. And so I began, at an early age, what I thought of as my life's work, the work of not dying a virgin.
我知道这种事也可能发生在我身上。日子会变成月份，月份变成年份，最终我会死在一家廉价旅馆里，被葬在单一的墓地里，挤在父母墓地的侧面。于是，我在很小的时候就开始了我认为是我的人生使命，也就是不以处男之身死去的工作。
At 10 I met Varid, my first crush. She was in from Israel with her family, and was staying with our neighbors. Since this was the summer Grease came out, I invited Varid upstairs to our living room, where I played the soundtrack on our stereo. While it played, I danced for her. My feeling was that you had to give girls everything you had-- your showmanship, your best moves, even your dignity.
10岁时，我遇到了瓦里德，我的初恋。她和家人从以色列来，住在我们邻居家。由于那年夏天《油脂》上映了，我邀请瓦里德到我们客厅，在那里我用音响播放了原声带。音乐响起时，我为她跳舞。我的感觉是，你必须给女孩你所拥有的一切——你的表演才能，你最好的舞步，甚至你的尊严。
As the music played, Varid sat there with quiet indifference. At one point, I tried to bring her soul to life by lying down on our coffee table and spinning around on my stomach like a spastic Lazy Susan. When I did the splits, I fell to the ground with a ferocity that almost tore my scrotal sac in two.
音乐播放时，瓦里德坐在那里，带着安静的冷漠。有一次，我试图通过躺在咖啡桌上，像一个痉挛的懒人餐桌一样在肚子上旋转来点燃她的灵魂。当我做劈叉时，我猛地摔倒在地，差点把我的阴囊撕成两半。
Before Varid went back to Israel, I handed her all 10 Archie digests that I owned. I stacked them so all the spines lined up perfectly. I wanted them to look solemn and substantial, like a package wrapped in rope from the old country. "It's how I feel about you," I wanted to say, but her English was not good enough to understand. For the next several years, I would say some variation of these words to many different people, but no one's English was ever good enough to understand.
瓦里德回以色列之前，我给了她我拥有的全部10本《阿奇》文摘。我把它们叠好，书脊对齐。我想让它们看起来庄重而厚实，就像一捆从老家带出来的用绳子包好的包裹。“这是我对你的感觉，”我想这么说，但她的英语水平不足以理解。在接下来的几年里，我会对许多不同的人说这些话的变体，但没有人的英语好到能听懂。
At the age of 13, I entered the service industry. The self service industry. I spent all of my time listening to music like Yellow while fantasizing about the high school gym teacher play tether ball in her brassiere. Or Stevie Nicks strumming a guitar in her brassiere. Or in my darker moments, Golda Meir ruling a nation in her brassiere.
13岁时，我进入了服务行业。自我服务行业。我所有的时间都在听像《黄色》这样的音乐，同时幻想着高中体育老师穿着胸罩打拍球。或者史蒂薇·妮克丝穿着胸罩弹吉他。或者在我更阴暗的时刻，果尔达·梅厄穿着胸罩统治一个国家。
And then at 14 our family got one of those early model elephantine video machines. I rented early 80s teen sex comedies like Private Lessons, Private School for Girls, and Reform School Girl. I would make each 20-second shower scene last anywhere from six to seven hours. Pause, rewind, frame advance became my version of the holy trinity. One time, having lost the remote control to our VCR, I watched the entirety of Sorority Girls on Vacation lying on the basement floor with the VCR on my chest, hitting its buttons like a 70 pound accordion.
然后在14岁时，我们家有了那款早期型号的巨型录像机。我租了80年代早期的青少年性喜剧，像《私人课程》、《女子私立学校》和《感化院女孩》。我会把每一个20秒的淋浴场景播放个六七个小时。暂停、倒带、逐帧播放成了我的三位一体。有一次，因为弄丢了录像机的遥控器，我躺在地下室的地板上，把录像机放在胸口，像手风琴一样按着它的按钮。
It was around that time, inspired by a potent cocktail of sexual desperation and movies starring Phoebe Cates, that I left the comfort of home for the streets. A 4 foot, 10 inch, pheromone-drenched Cabbage Patch doll with acne on the prowl. And thus at 16, I met Tamara. Everyone had a locker partner at our school, and I shared mine with Tamara. Just knowing that no matter what, our winter boots were alone in the dark together for six hours a day was enough to make me feel at least that something in my life was going all right.
就在那时，受到性绝望和菲比·凯茨主演的电影的刺激，我离开了舒适的家，走向街头。一个4英尺10英寸、充满荷尔蒙、长满痘痘的卷心菜娃娃在出没。于是，在16岁时，我遇到了塔玛拉。学校里的每个人都有储物柜搭档，我和塔玛拉共用一个。只要知道无论如何，我们的冬靴每天有六个小时在黑暗中待在一起，就足以让我觉得我的人生至少有一点进展。
One day I finally worked up the courage to ask her if she wanted to see the Eurythmics concert with me, because I knew she was a big fan, and she said yes. I don't know where I came up with the idea, but I had decided at some point during the concert that I wanted to hold Tamara from behind and sway with her back and forth to the music. It was all I could think about all night. It wasn't a kiss or a held hand I was after, but something else, something less definable. It was like I wanted to prove that I could get us into some kind of groove.
有一天，我终于鼓起勇气问她想不想和我一起去看Eurythmics演唱会，因为我知道她是他们的超级粉丝，她答应了。我不知道这个想法是从哪儿冒出来的，但在演唱会期间的某个时刻，我决定我想从背后抱着塔玛拉，随着音乐和她一起摇摆。整晚我满脑子都是这个。我追求的不是吻或牵手，而是别的东西，一些更难定义的东西。我就好像想证明我能把我们带入某种节奏。
Finally, during a slow song, I snuck up behind her and put my sweaty pocket hands on her hips. I tried to ease us into it. My movements were halted and completely non-musical. Rather than dancing, it looked like I was trying to hoist a resistant woman into a mailbox while in the throes of a painful piles attack. Tamara freed herself, and for the rest of the evening, she was afraid to come near me.
最终，在一首慢歌中，我溜到她身后，把汗津津的手放在她的臀部上。我试图让我们进入状态。我的动作很生硬，完全没有音乐感。与其说是跳舞，看起来倒更像是在痔疮发作的剧痛中试图把一个反抗的女人塞进邮箱。塔玛拉挣脱了，那天晚上剩下的时间里，她都不敢靠近我。
At home that night I ate a bowl of cold cereal was staring at a bottle of my mother's nail polish on the kitchen counter. Carefully I painted my nails. In bed, my fingers spider-walked the length of my ribs. "Quit tickling me," I told myself. "I have to make this an early night." I grabbed my hand and flung it away from myself roughly. but it always crept back.
那天晚上在家，我吃了一碗冷麦片，盯着厨房柜台上我母亲的指甲油瓶。我小心翼翼地涂了指甲。在床上，我的手指像蜘蛛一样爬过肋骨。“别挠我，”我对自己说。“我得早点睡。”我抓住自己的手，粗暴地甩开。但它总是又爬了回来。
If early 80s teen sex comedies had taught me anything, which, unfortunately, they had in abundance, it was that college was going to be a nonstop nookie fest. I wasn't fat enough to be the one who sees undressing sorority girls shortly before falling backwards from a ladder. Nor was I daring enough to have sex with a friend's mom. Nor was I near sighted and good enough at science to create a fellatio bot.
如果80年代早期的青少年性喜剧教会了我什么（不幸的是，它们确实教会了我很多），那就是大学将是一场永无止境的性爱派对。我没胖到那种会在看更衣室女孩换衣服时从梯子上向后摔倒的笨蛋程度。我也没胆量和朋友的妈妈发生关系。我也没近视到能创造出一个口交机器人的科学天才程度。
But I did know that I was the nice guy, the one that drove everyone around on their way to getting action, and that before the credits rolled, I would receive my due. It was only right. Well, the credits had rolled, the curtain had come down, there was a man sweeping up popcorn, and still no due.
但我确实知道我是那个好人，那个在送别人去搞对象时负责开车的人，而且在片尾字幕滚动之前，我会得到我应得的回报。这是理所当然的。好吧，字幕滚动了，幕布拉下了，有个男人在扫爆米花，而我还是没得到应得的。
For winter break, my friend Howard and I decided to spend the week in New York City. As we rode the train there, we passed a burned out school bus in a field, and I thought, yes, that is my heart. My heart is a burned out school bus with no windows sitting in the middle of nowhere. But then after about 15 minutes, the train passed a little gray wooden control booth, the door flung wide open, and I thought, no, that. That is my heart.
寒假期间，我和朋友霍华德决定在纽约市待上一周。当我们乘火车去那里时，我们经过田野里一辆烧毁的校车，我想，是的，那就是我的心。我的心是一辆烧毁的、没有窗户的校车，停在虚无之中。但大约15分钟后，火车经过一个小小的灰色木质控制亭，门敞开着，我想，不，是那个。那才是我的心。
The train continued along through February fields, and I looked for more things to call my heart. A rusty bridge. A chopped down evergreen. A discarded can of Mountain Dew. It turned out my heart was everywhere that winter month.
火车继续穿过二月的田野，我寻找更多可以称为我心的东西。一座生锈的桥。一棵被砍倒的常青树。一个丢弃的山露汽水罐。结果那天冬天，我的心无处不在。
We stayed with Howard's aunt in Flushing, and every night we would go to the local bar and take pictures of ourselves scribbling in our notebooks, our faces illuminated by the neon jukebox. It was at that bar that we met a 25-year-old Venezuelan furniture salesman named Jose. Howard and I thought Jose was the coolest. While we drank our rum and Coca-Cola's, Jose drank bloody caesars, something we considered very sophisticated, sort of like drinking a salad.
我们住在霍华德在法拉盛的姑妈家，每天晚上我们都会去当地的酒吧，拍下自己在笔记本上乱涂乱画的照片，我们的脸被霓虹灯点唱机照亮。就在那家酒吧里，我们遇到了一个25岁的委内瑞拉家具销售员，名叫何塞。霍华德和我觉得何塞酷毙了。当我们喝着朗姆可乐时，何塞喝着血腥凯撒，我们认为这非常高级，有点像是在喝沙拉。
Howard explained his dilemma to Jose, and I explained mine. Howard had had cancer when he was 16 and was concerned he wouldn't ever be able to produce semen and have children. I explained that I had grown weary of being a virgin and really, really wanted to see naked chimichangas. Jose furrowed his brow and listened to our problems with concern. Then he said he was taking us to a whore house.
霍华德向何塞解释了他的困境，我也解释了我的。霍华德16岁时患过癌症，担心自己永远无法产生精子，生儿育女。我解释说我厌倦了做处男，非常、非常想看裸体的墨西哥卷饼。何塞皱着眉头，关切地听着我们的问题。然后他说他要带我们去妓院。
I cottoned to the idea of a whore house by telling myself that I was very old school, very Neil Simon, or Burt Reynolds, or something. It was probably how my father and his father before him did it. I imagined my grandfather had lost his virginity to a kind-hearted madam, who, after the deed, had cooked him a brisket.
我接受了去妓院的想法，因为我告诉自己，我非常老派，非常尼尔·西蒙，或者是伯特·雷诺兹之流。我父亲和他父亲之前可能也是这么做的。我想象着我的祖父是在一位心地善良的老鸨那里失去了童贞，她在完事后还给他做了一份牛腩。
Jose took us to an apartment above a fruit store in Spanish Harlem, where we were invited in by a small, older Latino man wearing a shoulder holster. Jose told us not to worry, that this is how things were done. We were seated on a couch facing an East Indian man and what appeared to be his two teenage sons. There were three women dressed in nighties who walked by carrying balled-up faded linen and punch bowl-sized metal basins with soapy sponges.
何塞带我们去了西班牙哈莱姆区一家水果店楼上的公寓，一个穿着肩挂式枪套、身材矮小的老拉丁裔男人邀请我们进去。何塞告诉我们不用担心，事情就是这样办的。我们坐在沙发上，对面坐着一个印度男人和他看起来像他两个十几岁的儿子的男孩。有三个穿着睡裙的女人走过，手里拿着揉成一团的褪色亚麻布和装有肥皂水的碗状金属盆。
It was after seeing the basins that I realized I would never be able to pull this off. There was something too medicinal and matter-of-fact about the whole thing. Not only that, but I was terrified. Sex was one thing, but if I was going to be getting naked on a strange bed with sheets that were dubious, I at least wanted to be with someone who mildly liked me. And that, of course, is something impossible to gauge when the exchange of Canadian travelers cheques is involved.
看到那些盆子后，我意识到我永远无法完成这件事。整个过程有一种过于医疗化和实事求是的氛围。不仅如此，我还吓坏了。性是一回事，但如果我要在一个床单可疑的陌生床上裸体，我至少希望和一个稍微喜欢我的人在一起。而这，当然是在涉及兑换加拿大旅行支票时无法衡量的事情。
I told Jose I would sit this one out. Howard, on the other hand, was raring to go. A woman came over to him and introduced herself as Crystal. Howard introduced himself as Mr. Cohenovsky, which was the name of our grade seven math teacher. Crystal took Howard by the hand and led him into a room.
我告诉何塞我要退出。另一方面，霍华德却跃跃欲试。一个女人走过来，介绍自己叫克里斯特尔。霍华德介绍自己是科恩诺夫斯基先生，那是我们七年级数学老师的名字。克里斯特尔牵起霍华德的手，把他领进了一个房间。
Each person got 20 minutes. Howard remained in the room with Crystal for 40. The Indian man sitting opposite me kept pointing to his watch while smiling and winking. There's nothing that makes you think about dying a virgin more than sitting on the couch in a whore house waiting for your best friend to finish having sex. That couch just then felt like the loneliest place on earth.
每个人20分钟。霍华德和克里斯特尔在房间里待了40分钟。坐在我斜对面的那个印度男人不停地指着他的手表，同时对我微笑眨眼。没有什么比坐在妓院的沙发上等最好的朋友完事更让人想起死于处男之身的了。那一刻，那张沙发感觉像是地球上最孤独的地方。
As it turned out, Crystal saw Howard's scar, and they spent most of their time together talking about what it was like to have had cancer. Crystal had lost a brother to leukemia several years earlier. She told Howard that when her and her brother were kids, they poked toothpicks into bubble gum, which they ate like hors d'oeuvres. She told Howard that she missed her brother very much.
事实证明，克里斯特尔看到了霍华德的伤疤，他们在一起的大部分时间都在谈论患过癌症是什么感觉。克里斯特尔几年前因白血病失去了弟弟。她告诉霍华德，当她和弟弟小时候，他们会把牙签插在泡泡糖上吃，就像吃开胃小菜一样。她告诉霍华德她非常想念弟弟。
On the walk back to the subway, I lagged behind Howard, just watching him. Eventually we asked Howard how it was with Crystal, and he said that it was different than he thought it would be. And Jose told him he was being too emotional.
走回地铁的路上，我落后在霍华德身后，只是看着他。最终我们问霍华德和克里斯特尔在一起感觉如何，他说这和预想的不一样。何塞告诉他太情绪化了。
What I hadn't taken into account was that before you lose something-- in this case, the albatross of one's virginity-- you had to first find something to enable that loss. At 18, sort of by accident, I found Galeet. Her name meant, "little wave," and when we kissed, it was like a little wave of blood was sweeping through my chest. We kissed long and hard, our eyes wide open.
我没有考虑到的事情是，在你失去某样东西之前——在这个例子中，是处男之身的枷锁——你必须先找到某种能让这种丧失发生的东西。18岁时，某种程度上是偶然，我找到了加莉特。她的名字意为“小浪”，当我们接吻时，就像一股小浪涌过我的胸膛。我们吻得很长很深，眼睛睁得大大的。
Galeet's face was always sad. I told her she had a frown that lit up a room. Galeet would be the first person I would ever sleep with, yet losing my virginity with her, even just after it happened, was something I can never remember. I could still recall what her breath smelled like after she had eaten chocolate, how she would almost cry when she saw little boys with big glasses. I remember a thousand other small things, too, yet our first time together, this thing that I waited forever to happen, to lose a virginity I had waited forever to lose, was completely and utterly lost to me.
加莉特的脸上总带着忧伤。我告诉她，她的眉头能照亮整个房间。加莉特是我第一个发生关系的女人，然而与她失去童贞，即使就在刚刚发生之后，也是我永远无法回忆起来的事情。我仍然记得她吃过巧克力后呼吸的味道，记得她看到戴着大眼镜的小男孩时几乎要哭出来的样子。我还记得一千件其他的小事，然而我们第一次在一起，这个我等待了永远才发生的事情，要失去我等待了永远才失去的童贞，对我来说却完全彻底地消失了。
I'm not sure I understand why this is. Maybe when you're coming towards it, it looks so big and all-eclipsing. It looks like the finish line. You imagine champagne, well wishers, certificates of merit. Then you reach it, and pass it, and you understand it's only the entry point to a lot of other worries, worries that prove to be much more immeasurable and complicated.
我不确定为什么会这样。也许当你接近它时，它看起来是那么巨大而遮天蔽日。它看起来像是终点线。你想象着香槟、祝福者、优异证书。然后你到达了它，越过了它，你才明白它仅仅是通向许多其他烦恼的入口，那些烦恼被证明要复杂和无法衡量得多。
My fear of losing my virginity was nothing compared to my fear of losing Galeet. I could never fathom how she could love me, and so I tested her love all the time. "Let's say I smashed your car," I said.
我对失去童贞的恐惧，与我对失去加莉特的恐惧相比根本不算什么。我永远无法理解她怎么能爱我，所以我一直在测试她的爱。“假设我撞坏了你的车，”我说。
"Then I'd kill you," she said.
“那我杀了你，”她说。
"But you'd still love me?"
“但你还会爱我吗？”
"I guess so," she said.
“我想会吧，”她说。
Before I met Galeet, I called myself a virgin. It was very clear and definite-- a virgin. Now there is no name for what I am. But I'm sort of partial to Leroy.
在遇到加莉特之前，我称自己为处男。这很明确，很确定——一个处男。现在我已经没有名字了。但我有点喜欢“勒罗伊”这个名字。
Thanks.
谢谢。
[AUDIENCE APPLAUDING]
[观众鼓掌]
Jonathan Goldstein. He's the author of the novel, Lenny Bruce Is Dead. Jonathan's next book, which he's working on right now, is a rewrite of the bible.
乔纳森·戈尔茨坦。他是小说《莱尼·布鲁斯之死》的作者。乔纳森正在写的下一本书，是对圣经的重写。
[MUSIC - "TOUCH TO HAVE A CRUSH" BY OK GO]
[音乐 - OK Go乐队的“TOUCH TO HAVE A CRUSH”]
[AUDIENCE APPLAUDING]
[观众鼓掌]
OK Go.
OK Go乐队。
Act Two. Teacher Hit Me With a Ruler.
第二幕。老师用尺子打我。
Can a song have skeletons in its closet? For this next act, Sarah Vowell decided to excavate the lost mongrel past of a patriotic song that I am sure you know. As songs go, it definitely had its wild party years before it settled down into the sort of thing that is played now at the White House, much like the current resident of the White House.
一首歌能有不可告人的秘密吗？对于下一幕，萨拉·沃威尔决定挖掘一首你一定熟悉的爱国歌曲背后那段失落的杂种历史。作为歌曲，在它定型为现在在白宫演奏的那种东西之前，它绝对经历了狂野的派对岁月，就像现任白宫主人一样。
I have to say, I love the fact that that man was a drunk. That's one of my favorite things about him. Is that wrong? Shows character.
我得说，我喜欢那个男人是个酒鬼的事实。这是关于他我最喜欢的事情之一。这不对吗？显示个性。
Please welcome Sarah Vowell.
请欢迎萨拉·沃威尔。
[AUDIENCE APPLAUDING]
[观众鼓掌]
At the memorial service at the National Cathedral on September 14, 2001, those gathered in the pews to mourn the more than 2,800 people who were murdered by terrorists three days before sang "The Battle Hymn of The Republic."
2001年9月14日，在国家大教堂举行的纪念仪式上，聚集在长椅上哀悼三天前被恐怖分子谋杀的2800多名受害者的人们唱起了《共和国战歌》。
[MUSIC - "BATTLE HYMN OF THE REPUBLIC" BY JON LANGFORD AND THE LOST IN AMERICA TOUR BAND] Mine eyes have seen the glory of the coming of the Lord: He is trampling out the vintage where the grapes of wrath are stored; He hath loosed the fateful lightning of His terrible swift sword: His truth is marching on.
[音乐 - 乔恩·兰福德和“迷失在美国”巡演乐队的“共和国战歌”] 我的双眼见证了主降临的荣光：他正踩踏着盛满愤怒葡萄的酒槽；他释放了可怕迅捷的闪电之剑：他的真理永向前进。
President Bush sang it. Ex-presidents Clinton, Carter, and Bush sang it. Watching it on television in New York City, I sang it. And across the sea at another service in another church, Queen Elizabeth sang it with tears in her English eyes, having sung the song 36 years earlier at the funeral of Winston Churchill, as Churchill himself had sung it along with FDR on the White House lawn in 1943.
布什总统唱了它。前总统克林顿、卡特和布什都唱了。我在纽约的电视上看着它，我唱了。而在大洋彼岸的另一座教堂的另一个仪式上，伊丽莎白女王含着泪水唱了它，她曾在36年前温斯顿·丘吉尔的葬礼上唱过这首歌，正如丘吉尔本人在1943年与罗斯福总统在白宫草坪上一起唱的那样。
Because that's when we sing "The Battle Hymn of the Republic," at wars and funerals. So "The Battle Hymn" was doubly appropriate on September 14. It was a funeral, we were at war.
因为那就是我们唱《共和国战歌》的时候，在战争和葬礼上。所以《战歌》在9月14日是双重适宜的。这是一场葬礼，我们正处于战争之中。
And yet there we were, we gathered Americans, her Majesty the queen, chanting this beloved battle cry at the terrorists of the world. And buried inside the melody of the song was the rotting corpse of an American terrorist. Here are the lyrics that used to go to that tune back in 1860, lyrics that honor the terrorist as a hero.
然而我们就在那里，聚集的美国人，女王陛下，向世界上的恐怖分子高唱这首深受喜爱的战斗口号。而埋藏在这首歌的旋律之中的，是一个美国恐怖分子的腐烂尸体。这是1860年那首歌原本的歌词，歌词将那个恐怖分子尊为英雄。
[MUSIC - "JOHN BROWN'S BODY" BY JON LANGFORD AND THE LOST IN AMERICA TOUR BAND] John brown's body lies moldering in the grave, John Brown's body lies moldering in the grave. John Brown's body lies moldering in the grave; his soul goes marching on.
[音乐 - 乔恩·兰福德和“迷失在美国”巡演乐队的“约翰·布朗之躯”] 约翰·布朗的身体躺在坟墓中腐烂，约翰·布朗的身体躺在坟墓中腐烂。约翰·布朗的身体躺在坟墓中腐烂；他的灵魂依然前进。
I don't throw around the word terrorist lightly, but if it's John Brown-- Brown, a white man who hated slavery so much that even his friend, the famed abolitionist and former slave Frederick Douglass, wished Brown would shut up about it every now and then. Back in 1856, Brown and his men massacred five pro-slavery settlers from the south near Pottawatomie Creek, Kansas, dragging them from their homes as their wives and children looked on screaming. They hacked them up with knives, though Brown shot one man's mangled body in the head just to make certain he was dead for sure.
我不会轻易使用“恐怖分子”这个词，但如果那是约翰·布朗——布朗，一个憎恨奴隶制到连他的朋友、著名废奴主义者和前奴隶弗雷德里克·道格拉斯都希望他偶尔闭嘴的白人。早在1856年，布朗和他的部下在堪萨斯州的波塔瓦托米溪附近屠杀了五名来自南方的支持奴隶制的定居者，在他们的妻子和孩子尖叫围观下，将他们从家中拖出。他们用刀将他们砍死，尽管布朗又对着其中一具血肉模糊的尸体的头部开了一枪，只是为了确定他确实死透了。
Then hoping to incite a slave uprising, Brown led a guerrilla attack on the Federal Arsenal at Harper's Ferry, Virginia on October 16, 1859. 17 people lost their lives, including 10 of Brown's men, two of whom were his sons. Brown was executed on December 2, 1859.
然后为了煽动奴隶起义，布朗于1859年10月16日对弗吉尼亚州哈珀斯费里的联邦军火库发动了游击袭击。17人丧生，包括布朗的10名部下，其中两人是他的儿子。布朗于1859年12月2日被处决。
Across the land, Brown's execution was either celebrated or mourned with the ringing church bells, depending on which side of the Mason Dixon Line one hung one's heart. In Concord, Massachusetts, Brown's friends, including Ralph Waldo Emerson, held a service in which Henry David Thoreau called Brown a crucified hero. Thoreau was so excited about Brown's martyrdom to the abolitionist cause, that he cheered that Brown's death gave people who were contemplating suicide, quote, "something to live for," exclamation point. And, as Lincoln puts it in his second inaugural, "the war came."
在全国范围内，布朗的处决要么被庆祝，要么在教堂钟声中被哀悼，这取决于一个人的心挂在哪一边。在马萨诸塞州的康科德，包括拉尔夫·沃尔多·爱默生在内的布朗的朋友们举行了一场仪式，亨利·大卫·梭罗称布朗为受难的英雄。梭罗对布朗为废奴事业殉难感到如此兴奋，以至于他欢呼道，布朗的死给了那些考虑自杀的人，“活下去的理由”，感叹号。而且，正如林肯在第二次就职演说中所说，“战争来了”。
Then John Brown got a song of his own, sort of. Like every turn in this story, the song "John Brown's Body" is an accident of history. What happened was Union soldiers-- the 12th Massachusetts Regiment-- were stationed at Fort Warren in Boston Harbor. As they went about their duties, the soldiers sang. One of their favorites was this Methodist hymn:
然后约翰·布朗有了属于他自己的歌，某种程度上。就像这个故事里的每一个转折点，歌曲“约翰·布朗之躯”是历史的一个意外。事情是这样的：联邦军队——马萨诸塞第12团——驻扎在波士顿港的沃伦堡。当他们履行职责时，士兵们唱歌。他们最喜欢的歌曲之一是这首卫理公会赞美诗：
[MUSIC - "SAY, BROTHERS, WON'T YOU MEET US" BY JON LANGFORD] Say, brother, will you meet us on Canaan's happy shore?
[音乐 - 乔恩·兰福德的“兄弟们，你们愿意在迦南海岸迎接我们吗”] 兄弟们，你们愿意在迦南的幸福海岸迎接我们吗？
There was a singing quartet in residence at the fort: Sergeant Charles Edgerly, Sergeant Newton J. Purnette, Sergeant James Jenkins, and Sergeant John Brown. One day in December of 1859, news arrived at the fort about the famous abolitionist. John Brown is dead. Some smart alec, thinking of his singing comrade Sergeant John Brown, is said to have replied, "but he still goes marching around."
堡垒里有一个驻扎的歌唱四重奏组：查尔斯·埃杰利中士、牛顿·J·普内特中士、詹姆斯·詹金斯中士和约翰·布朗中士。1859年12月的一天，关于那位著名废奴主义者的消息传到了堡垒。约翰·布朗死了。一些聪明人，想到他的歌唱同伴约翰·布朗中士，据说回答说：“但他依然在前进。”
A soldier named Henry Howgreen reportedly turned this wise crack into the first verse of the song about his comrade, "John Brown's body lies moldering in the grave, his soul goes marching on." A soldier who played the organ set it to the music of "Say, Brothers, Won't You Meet Us." So the song was a joke, joshing among soldiers, the sort of ribbing a sergeant in today's army might get if he had the misfortune of being named Uday Hussein.
一名名叫亨利·豪格林的士兵据称把这个笑话变成了关于他同伴的歌的第一节：“约翰·布朗的身体躺在坟墓中腐烂，他的灵魂依然前进。”一位弹风琴的士兵将它配上了“兄弟们，你们愿意迎接我们吗”的曲子。所以这首歌是一个玩笑，士兵们之间的调侃，就像今天军队里的中士如果不幸被取名为乌代·侯赛因可能会遭受的那种揶揄。
"John Brown's Body" became the regiment's marching song. They sang in public for the first time, here in Boston on State Street, on July 18, 1861. After that, they sang it marching down Broadway in New York City. They sang it so often they became known as The Hallelujah Regiment. On March 1, 1862, they sang in Virginia on the very spot the abolitionist John Brown was hanged.
“约翰·布朗之躯”成了该团的行军歌曲。1861年7月18日，他们第一次在波士顿州街公开演唱。之后，他们在纽约百老汇行军时也唱了它。他们唱得如此频繁，以至于被称为“哈利路亚团”。1862年3月1日，他们在弗吉尼亚州演唱，就在那位废奴主义者约翰·布朗被绞死的地方。
Three months later, Sergeant John Brown drowned while crossing the Shenandoah River on his way to battle. Heartbroken, The Hallelujah Regiment never sang "John Brown's Body" again. But by that time, they were the only ones in the Union Army not singing it. Northern soldiers would sing it on parade, marching from battle to battle, sitting around camp fires at night. And since no one had ever heard of Sergeant Brown, every soldier who sang the song thought he was paying tribute to the famed abolitionist.
三个月后，约翰·布朗中士在横渡谢南多厄河参加战斗时淹死了。伤心欲绝的“哈利路亚团”再也没有唱过“约翰·布朗之躯”。但到那时，他们已经是联邦军队中唯一不唱这首歌的人了。北方士兵在阅兵时、从一场战斗行军到另一场战斗时、晚上在营火旁都会唱这首歌。而且由于没有人听说过布朗中士，每个唱这首歌的士兵都认为他是在向那位著名的废奴主义者致敬。
Lyrics kept getting added on, including one doozy of a stanza about the president of the confederacy.
歌词不断被添加，包括关于邦联总统的一节荒唐的歌词。
[MUSIC - "JOHN BROWN'S BODY" BY JON LANGFORD AND THE LOST IN AMERICA TOUR BAND] We'll hang Jeff Davis to a sour apple tree, we'll hang Jeff Davis to a sour apple tree. We'll hang Jeff Davis to a sour apple tree; as we go marching on.
[音乐 - 乔恩·兰福德和“迷失在美国”巡演乐队的“约翰·布朗之躯”] 我们要把杰夫·戴维斯吊在酸苹果树上，要把杰夫·戴维斯吊在酸苹果树上，要把杰夫·戴维斯吊在酸苹果树上；我们继续前进。
In November of 1861, some white abolitionists from Boston, including Mr. and Mrs. Samuel Gridley Howe, and their minister Reverend James F. Clark, were touring a Union army base on the outskirts of the nation's capital. They heard some soldiers singing about John Brown's body "moldering in the grave." Reverend Clark turned to Mrs. Howe and wondered if she might like to write new, more uplifting lyrics to that fine melody of "John Brown's Body."
1861年11月，来自波士顿的一些白人废奴主义者，包括塞缪尔·格里德利·豪夫妇和他们的牧师詹姆斯·F·克拉克，正在参观国家首都郊外的一个联邦陆军基地。他们听到一些士兵唱着约翰·布朗的身体“在坟墓中腐烂”。克拉克牧师转向豪夫人，想知道她是否愿意为“约翰·布朗之躯”那优美的旋律写下新的、更令人振奋的歌词。
Not that Julia Ward Howe had a problem with John Brown. She had even hosted Brown at dinner in her home on one of his trips to Massachusetts, trying to drum up money he could use smiting the slave mongers. Basically, abolitionist pledge drive.
并不是说朱莉娅·沃德·豪对约翰·布朗有什么意见。她甚至在马萨诸塞州的一次旅行中在家里接待过布朗，试图帮他筹钱去打击奴隶贩子。基本上就是废奴主义者的募捐活动。
You are the public in public hanging.
你是公开绞刑中的公众。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
Julia Ward Howe would recall of the morning she wrote new lyrics that she had "the feeling that something of importance had happened to me." Back home in Boston, she gave the poem to her neighbor, James T. Fields, editor of the Atlantic Monthly. He paid Howe $4.00, gave her poem the title, "The Battle Hymn of the Republic," and published it in the February 1862 issue. "The Battle Hymn" became a huge hit. Who knew the Atlantic Monthly was the TRL of its day?
朱莉娅·沃德·豪在回忆写下新歌词的那天早晨时，说她有“一种重要的事情发生在我身上的感觉”。回到波士顿，她把这首诗给了邻居詹姆斯·T·菲尔兹，他是《大西洋月刊》的编辑。他付给豪4美元，给她的诗起了个名字叫《共和国战歌》，并发表在1862年2月号上。《战歌》成了巨大的成功。谁知道《大西洋月刊》是当时的MTV热歌排行榜呢？
Soldiers and citizens alike couldn't stop singing it. When Abraham Lincoln heard it at a rally, it is said that his eyes filled with tears and he yelled, "sing it again."
士兵和公民们都无法停止传唱它。当亚伯拉罕·林肯在集会上听到它时，据说他的双眼盈满了泪水，大喊道：“再唱一遍。”
Sing it again.
再唱一遍。
[MUSIC - "THE BATTLE HYMN OF THE REPUBLIC" BY JON LANGFORD AND THE LOST IN AMERICA TOUR BAND] I have read a fiery gospel writ in burnished rows of steel: "As ye deal with my contemners, so with you my grace shall deal; let the hero born of woman crush the serpent with his heel, since God is marching on."
[音乐 - 乔恩·兰福德和“迷失在美国”巡演乐队的“共和国战歌”] 我读过用钢铁烧制的炽热福音：“既然你们对待我的蔑视者，那么我的恩典也会那样对待你们；让妇女所生的英雄用脚跟粉碎那条毒蛇，因为上帝依然前进。”
That line in the hymn about the hero born of woman, which is a shout-out to the Virgin Mary by way of William Shakespeare, takes on an extra meaning in light of Julia Ward Howe's biography. Though she was married for 34 years, raised six children, and is, in fact, the creator of Mother's Day, Julia how was not without ambivalence about domesticity. For example, she wrote a poem entitled "The Present is Dead. " On her honeymoon. In writing to her sister about what she called "the stupor of marriage and motherhood," Howe complained, "it has been like blindness, like death, like exile from all things beautiful and good."
赞美诗中关于“妇女所生的英雄”的那一行，是对威廉·莎士比亚笔下圣母玛利亚的致敬，在朱莉娅·沃德·豪的生平背景下有了额外的含义。虽然她结婚34年，抚养了六个孩子，并且实际上还是“母亲节”的创造者，但朱莉娅·豪对家庭主妇的生活并非没有矛盾。例如，她在度蜜月时写了一首题为《现在已死》的诗。在给姐妹写信描述她所谓的“婚姻和母亲身份的昏迷”时，豪抱怨道：“这就像失明，像死亡，像被放逐出所有美好和善良的事物。”
So in "The Battle Hymn of the Republic," Howe reminds the nations that the Son of God had a human mom who did all the work. Hence, "let the hero born of woman crush the serpent with his heel," Howe is rubbing in the fact that even Jesus had to be potty trained.
所以在《共和国战歌》中，豪提醒各国，上帝之子有一位做尽所有工作的凡人母亲。因此，“让妇女所生的英雄用脚跟粉碎那条毒蛇”，豪在提醒人们，甚至连耶稣也得学习如厕训练。
Like a lot of your bigger hit songs, "The Battle Hymn" has been ripped off numerous times. Countless renditions have been sent to its tune, which is fair enough considering that Julia Ward Howe ripped off a song which was a rip off of a previous song. There was "Solidarity Forever," a union number from the IWW songbook.
像很多热门歌曲一样，《战歌》被翻唱过无数次。它的旋律被用过无数次，考虑到朱莉娅·沃德·豪窃取了一首歌，而那首歌本身又是对之前一首歌的窃取，这倒也公平。还有“团结永远”，来自IWW歌集的一首工会歌曲。
[MUSIC - "SOLIDARITY FOREVER" BY JON LANGFORD AND THE LOST IN AMERICA TOUR BAND] When the union's inspiration through the workers' blood shall run, there can be no greater anywhere beneath the sun; yet what force on earth weaker than the feeble strength of one, for the union makes us strong.
[音乐 - 乔恩·兰福德和“迷失在美国”巡演乐队的“团结永远”] 当工会的灵感流经工人的血液，太阳之下再无更伟大的事；还有什么力量比个人的微弱力量更薄弱，因为工会使我们强大。
There was "Glory Land," the official song for the 1994 World Cup, in which Darryl Hall, of and Oates fame, proclaimed to the soccer fans, "with passion rising high, you know that you can reach your goal."
还有“荣耀之地”，1994年世界杯的官方歌曲，达里尔·霍尔（著名组合Hall & Oates成员）在歌中向足球迷们宣告，“激情高涨时，你知道你可以实现你的目标。”
[AUDIENCE GROANING]
[观众呻吟]
I know.
我知道。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHING]
[观众笑声]
And of course, that playground classic:
当然，还有那个操场经典：
[MUSIC - "PLAYGROUND VERSION OF 'THE BATTLE HYMN'" BY JON LANGFORD AND THE LOST IN AMERICA BAND] Mine eyes have seen the glory of the burning of the school, we have tortured every teacher, we have broken every rule; we have marched unto the principal to tell him he's a fool, the school is burning down. The school is burning down.
[音乐 - 乔恩·兰福德和“迷失在美国”乐队的“操场版《战歌》”] 我的双眼见证了烧毁学校的荣光，我们折磨了每一位老师，我们打破了每一条规则；我们向校长行军告诉他他是傻瓜，学校正在燃烧。学校正在燃烧。
[AUDIENCE CHEERING]
[观众欢呼]
In the 1950s, around the time of the Korean War, something else happened to Julia Ward How's "Battle Hymn of the Republic." A word changed. The line "let us die to make men free" got change to "let us live to make man free." The new wording acknowledged that sometimes war isn't always the answer. Plus, less of a downer.
20世纪50年代，朝鲜战争时期，朱莉娅·沃德·豪的《共和国战歌》又发生了别的变化。一个词变了。“让我们牺牲以使人们自由”这一行改成了“让我们生活以使人类自由”。新的措辞承认战争并不总是答案。而且，没那么沮丧。
And through the years, a civil war of sorts has broken out between those who would die and those who would live. The Mormon Tabernacle Choir sings "live" on their 1959 Grammy Award-winning recording of the song. Joan Baez, leading a sing-along at a black college in Birmingham in 1962, went with the traditional "die."
多年来，在那些愿意牺牲的人和那些愿意生活的人之间爆发了一场某种意义上的内战。摩门教大礼拜堂合唱团在他们1959年获得格莱美奖的录音中唱的是“生活”。琼·贝兹在1962年伯明翰的一所黑人大学带领合唱时，用了传统的“牺牲”。
In my opinion, die is the way to go. When you get rid of the word, "die," you erase the most moving idea in the song, that if Christ died for us, we should be willing to die for each other. Why give that up? This the one clear-cut case where you can ask yourself, "what would Jesus do," and you know the answer. What would Jesus do? Die.
在我看来，牺牲才是应该选的。当你去掉了“牺牲”这个词，你就抹去了这首歌中最动人的理念：如果基督为我们牺牲，我们也应该愿意为彼此牺牲。为什么要放弃这个？这是一个你可以问自己“耶稣会怎么做”的明确案例，而且你知道答案。耶稣会怎么做？牺牲。
And, of course, people disagree about the wording. We disagree about everything else in this country. And when we sing the song today, I think we even disagree about who the serpents are that our heels should crush. Some of us see our enemies abroad, some see them at home, some of us are still mad at France. And that's the way it's been with this song all through its history. It gets adapted for one use, than another. The melody is so powerful, the words so strong, you feel like you really would lay down your life for a just cause. Of your choosing.
当然，人们对措辞有分歧。我们在这个国家的其他所有事情上都有分歧。今天当我们唱这首歌时，我想我们甚至对我们要粉碎的蛇是谁都有分歧。我们中的一些人看到了国外的敌人，一些人在国内看到了敌人，还有些人仍然对法国感到恼火。这就是这首歌在整个历史中的样子。它被改编用于一种用途，然后是另一种。旋律是如此强大，歌词是如此有力，你会觉得你真的会为正义事业贡献你的生命。你所选择的那种。
When we sing "The Battle Hymn"-- and I say we because that is how the song is traditionally performed at public events, as a sing-along in which a group of citizens turn themselves into a choir-- we sing about taking action, about marching on, about doing something. And this is the best part about singing "The Battle Hymn:" you're not standing there alone doing something, you're part of something. The song starts off with "mine eyes," and "I have seen," and by the end it's "you and me" and "let us die" or "let us live," whatever-- "us" being the point. We're all in it together, if only for the length of the song.
当我们唱《战歌》时——我说“我们”，因为这是这首歌在公共活动中作为集体演唱的传统表演方式，一群公民把自己变成了一个合唱团——我们唱的是采取行动，关于前进，关于做点什么。而这是唱《战歌》最好的一点：你不是独自一人站在那里做某事，你是某事的一部分。歌曲开始于“我的双眼”和“我已见证”，到最后变成了“你和我”和“让我们牺牲”或“让我们生活”，随它吧——重点是“我们”。我们都在一起，哪怕只是在那首歌的时间里。
Sarah Vowell. She's the author of several books, including The Partly Cloudy Patriot.
萨拉·沃威尔。她是包括《部分多云的爱国者》在内的几本书的作者。
Word about the band that's here in the stage. On this tour, we have the band OK Go. And we have this bad, headed by the seme-legendary Jon Langford of the Mekons in the Waco Brothers. A while back, John did a story with us and producer Starlee Kine on our staff in our show about the classified ads, we he put together an entire band from the musicians classifieds. And he's brought two of those musicians from that story with him here on the tour. On the far end you'll see Eric Muller on the theremin. Eric used to work for a company that made parts for the railroad. And on this end is Nathan Swanson, who still works part time for Home Depot, playing electric violin and mandolin. Alan on bass and Dan on drums, they're old pros.
说说在舞台上的乐队。在这次巡演中，我们有OK Go乐队。我们还有这支由来自Mekons乐队和Waco Brothers乐队、半传奇人物乔恩·兰福德领衔的乐队。前段时间，乔恩和我们制作组的斯塔莉·凯恩一起做了一个关于分类广告的故事，他把分类广告里的音乐家组织成了一支完整的乐队。他把故事里的那两名音乐家也带到了巡演中。在最远端你可以看到埃里克·穆勒在弹奏特雷门琴。埃里克曾经在一家生产铁路零件的公司工作。在这一端是内森·斯旺森，他还在家得宝兼职工作，演奏电小提琴和曼陀林。艾伦担任贝斯手，丹担任鼓手，他们都是老手。
[MUSIC - "HELL'S ROOF" BY JON LANGFORD AND THE LOST IN AMERICA TOUR BAND]
[音乐 - 乔恩·兰福德和“迷失在美国”巡演乐队的“地狱之顶”]
That was great.
太棒了。
Coming up, scraps of paper, personal letters, handmade signs, all discarded and then found. Maybe there's something of yours in there. You'll find out in a minute. From Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，纸片、私人信件、手工标语，全部被丢弃然后被找回。也许里面有你的东西。一会儿你就会知道。来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week, of course, we choose theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, taped on the road in Boston, Portland, Oregon, Denver, Chicago, and Washington DC: Lost in America. Stories of people who are lost, words that are lost, things that are lost, and, now and again, found.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们都会选择一个主题，为您带来围绕该主题的各种故事。今天的节目在波士顿、俄勒冈州波特兰、丹佛、芝加哥和华盛顿特区的路演中录制：《迷失在美国》。讲述关于迷失的人、迷失的文字、迷失的事物，以及偶尔被找回的故事。
We've arrived at Act Three of our program. Act Three: I Found Your Letter.
我们到达了节目的第三幕。第三幕：我找到了你的信。
You know when you're walking down the street and you spot some random piece of paper floating around-- a page from a letter, a shopping list with a note on it, some kid's paper from class-- do you pick it up? Do you read it? Me? Very nosy, yes.
你知道当你走在街上，发现一张随处飘荡的随机纸片——一封信的一页，写着备注的购物清单，某个孩子班级的作业纸——你会捡起来吗？你会读吗？我？非常好奇，是的。
As writing goes, these pieces of paper, they're little writing orphans, cut off from their original life, cut off from everything that gave them meaning. But still there with a lot on their minds and a lot to say.
文字作品来说，这些纸片是小的文字孤儿，与它们的原始生活切断，与赋予它们意义的一切切断。但它们仍然在那里，心中装着很多东西，有很多话要说。
A few years back, Davy Rothbart decided that somebody, somewhere should do a magazine that was made up entirely of this kind of writing. And then through sheer force of will, he became that somebody and created Found Magazine. Now, people all over the country send him this stuff. He's going to come out and read some of this writing that has been discarded and misplaced, lost by its original owners.
几年前，戴维·罗斯巴特决定，有人、在某处应该做一本完全由这种文字组成的杂志。然后凭借纯粹的意志力，他成了那个人，并创办了《发现》杂志。现在，全国各地的人们把这些东西寄给他。他要出来读一些被丢弃和放错位置、被其最初拥有者遗失的文字。
Please welcome Davy Rothbart.
请欢迎戴维·罗斯巴特。
[AUDIENCE APPLAUSE]
[观众鼓掌]
Everyone can find stuff. And I want to give you just a sense of some of the stuff that people are finding and sending in to us. This right here is a note that was found in LA.
每个人都能发现东西。我想让你感受一下人们正在发现并寄给我们的东西。这正是一张在洛杉矶发现的便条。
And it says, "Jesse, I did not take anything. I know there's no convincing you once you've made up your mind. And although I cannot offer you any other explanation as to what happened to it, that doesn't mean I did it. How could I have? You say your car was locked and Katie had the keys.
它写着，“杰西，我什么也没拿。我知道一旦你拿定主意，就没法说服你了。虽然我无法对它发生了什么给你任何其他的解释，但这并不意味着是我做的。我怎么可能做呢？你说你的车锁了，而凯蒂有钥匙。
Anyway, I don't need to take something of yours when I could get my own. It doesn't make sense. But here's a replacement, because I can't stand when you think I've wronged you. Mom."
无论如何，当我能自己搞到东西时，我不需要拿你的。这说不通。但这儿有一个替代品，因为我受不了你以为我冤枉了你。妈。”
[AUDIENCE LAUGHING]
[观众笑声]
The authors of some of these notes, they don't always paint themselves in the best light, you know? Sometimes they're going fine, fine, and they just skewer themselves at the end. And this is one that was found in Tacoma, Washington.
这些便条的作者，他们并不总是把自己写得很好，你知道吗？有时他们开头写得好好的，到最后却把自己给刺穿了。这是一张在华盛顿州塔科马发现的便条。
And at the top, OK, it just says, "what kind of relationship do I want? How do I see myself in it? I'm nurturing, I'm relied upon, I'm getting my ya-yas." But then down here it says, "what I hate about women: they're hard, impossible to please and satisfy. They talk a lot without saying much or being intimate. And they're self-involved and self-absorbed. I want them to be absorbed with me."
在顶部，好吧，它只写着，“我想要什么样的关系？我如何在其中看待自己？我是培养性的，我是被依赖的，我正在获得我的快乐。”但下面写着，“我讨厌女人的地方：她们很难，不可能取悦和满足。她们说很多话却什么也没说，也不亲密。而且她们以自我为中心，只关心自己。我希望她们关心我。”
This one was found in Berkeley, California, actually on the front lawn of a fraternity house. And it was a whole book of letters back and forth from the elders of the house to the pledges, the young kids who are trying to get into the fraternity. So this is one of the notes that's from one of the elders to one of the young pledges named A.J.
这张是在加州伯克利发现的，实际上是在一个兄弟会房子的前草坪上。那是整整一本书的信件，从房子的长辈来回写给准会员，那些试图进入兄弟会的年轻人。所以这是其中一张便条，从其中一位长辈写给名叫A.J.的年轻准会员的。
And he says, "A.J., tonight's event was just a tradition of the house. It was not gay. Even though you had to pull down your pants, at least you didn't have to show it to all the actives, just your pledge master. Its meaning: to prove your manhood and that you are not a boy. But none of us are gay. Aside from all this, I want to know that I've seen some improvement out of you since your first pledge. Keep up the effort and have a positive attitude of things. I tell ya, it's all worth it once you've crossed. Take my word for it. Just hang in there, OK?
他说，“A.J.，今晚的活动只是房子的传统。这不是同性恋。即使你不得不脱掉裤子，至少你不必展示给所有正式成员看，只要给你的入会指导者看就行。它的意义：证明你的男子气概，证明你不是个男孩。但我们中没有一个是同性恋。撇开所有这些，我想知道，自你第一次成为准会员以来，我确实看到你有所进步。保持努力，对事物持积极态度。我告诉你，一旦你跨过那一关，一切都是值得的。相信我。坚持下去，好吗？
Listen, I want you to have dinner with me when you're free someday. It's a great chance for you to get to know me better and for me to answer questions you may have, all right? Aaron."
听着，我希望你哪天有空时和我一起吃晚饭。这是你更好地了解我，以及我回答你可能有的问题的绝佳机会，好吗？亚伦。”
And so many of the notes, as I read through them when they come in the mail every day that people are finding, they deal with love and relationships, you know? And one of the favorite notes that I've ever found myself is this note I found in Chicago on my windshield. I came out of my friend's apartment late one night. It had snowed a little bit. And you know, with like a thin layer of snow, every car looks a little bit the same. And my name's Davy, but there's a note on my windshield that was addressed to Marco.
每天邮件中寄来的这么多便条，人们发现的，它们都处理爱情和关系，你知道吗？我曾经发现过的最喜欢的便条之一，是我在芝加哥的车窗上发现的。一天深夜，我从朋友公寓出来。下了一点雪。你知道，那一层薄薄的雪，每辆车看起来都有点一样。我的名字叫戴维，但车窗上的便条是写给马可的。
And it said, "Marco, I freakin' hate you. You said you had to work? Then why is your car here at her place? You're a freakin' liar. I hate you, I freakin' hate you. Crystal. P.S. Page me later?"
上面写着，“马可，我他妈讨厌你。你说你要工作？那为什么你的车在她那儿？你是个他妈的骗子。我讨厌你，我他妈讨厌你。克里斯特尔。附言：之后传呼我？”
And then this one just came in last week from-- it was found in North Carolina. And it says, "Dear Will, the longer I think about what I'm doing, the sicker I feel. Will, I'm sorry, but I don't think we should continue to have a relationship together. At least not as a couple. I love you, but things have not been the same since we found out that we were related."
还有这一张是上周刚收到的——它在北卡罗来纳州被发现。它写着，“亲爱的威尔，我越是思考我在做什么，我就越觉得恶心。威尔，对不起，但我认为我们不应该继续保持关系了。至少作为情侣不应该。我爱你，但自从我们发现我们有亲戚关系以来，事情就不一样了。”
[AUDIENCE LAUGHING]
[观众笑声]
My little brother, Peter, he is the best finder I know. He amazes me with what he brings home. And this is one he found when he was visiting me in Chicago. And it's written in like a kid's handwriting. It looks like maybe a 12-year-old kid. It says, "To cashier, will you please sell my son one pack of Newport Lights." Ah, that trick. "Thank you for your help." On there's just this scrawled, adult-looking signature.
我的弟弟彼得，他是我认识的最好的发现者。他带回家的东西让我震惊。这是他在芝加哥探望我时发现的一张。它是用孩子的笔迹写的。看起来像是一个12岁左右的孩子。上面写着，“给收银员，请卖给我儿子一包新港淡烟。”啊，那个诡计。“谢谢你的帮助。”上面只有一个乱糟糟、看起来像成年人的签名。
And then this one my brother found pinned under the back tire of his bicycle. And it's this handsome looking sign. Someone spent a good deal of time putting this thing together.
还有这一张是我弟弟在他的自行车后轮胎下发现的。这是一个看起来很帅气的标语。有人花了很多时间做这个东西。
It says, "After leaving the building please lock this door. It will prevent unauthorized people from entering the building and defecating in the washing machine. Many thanks."
上面写着，“离开大楼后请锁好这扇门。这将防止未经授权的人进入大楼并在洗衣机里排便。非常感谢。”
And when you send your finds in, I ask that you name your finds. And also that you write one line, you know, a sense of response or interpretation to it. About this one, my brother wrote, he says, "Note that those who are authorized to defecate in the washing machine will be given a key for entry."
当你把你的发现寄来时，我要求你给你的发现命名。而且你还要写下一行，你知道，一种回应或解释。关于这一张，我弟弟写道，他说，“请注意，那些被授权在洗衣机里排便的人将获得一把入口钥匙。”
And yeah, I applaud for whoever made that sign, but also for my brother, who just picked it up off the ground. And I asked him, you know, "how do you do it? What's your secret?" My brother says that it's been scientifically calculated-- by him-- that one in five, 20%, of all finds are gems of finds. So that means if you pick one thing up a day, that every week you'll have a real jewel of a find.
是的，我为制作那个标语的人鼓掌，也为我弟弟鼓掌，他只是把它从地上捡了起来。我问他，“你怎么做到的？你的秘密是什么？”我弟弟说经过科学计算——由他自己计算——所有的发现中，有五分之一，即20%是极品。这意味着如果你每天捡一样东西，每周你就会有一个真正的珠宝般的发现。
Let's read this one here. This is from Erie, Pennsylvania. And it's a note, a kid writing a letter to his dad.
读一下这个。这是来自宾夕法尼亚州伊利的。这是一张便条，一个孩子写给他爸爸的信。
It says, "Hi, Dad. What's up? Not much here. Just working to save money. I'm working at Old Country Buffet starting at $6.50 an hour cooking. Dad, are there any cooking jobs down there? Let me know when you write me back. I gave Cleav your letter, OK? Without Mom knowing, OK?
上面写着，“嘿，爸爸。你好吗？我这儿没什么。就是打工攒钱。我在老乡村自助餐打工，时薪6.50美元负责做饭。爸爸，那儿有做饭的工作吗？回信的时候告诉我。我把你的信给克里夫了，好吗？别让妈妈知道，好吗？
I can't wait to come down there. Erie sucks bad. There ain't nothing to do. Too cold. The weather sucks, too. Dad, I drink, too. Beer. Budweiser. But I don't drink a lot. And I do a little drugs, too. I smoke joints. And I got a bowl that's cool. I'll let you see it, OK? I talked to Grandma. She said she's going to send you a letter and some money.
我等不及要下去了。伊利太烂了。没啥可做的。太冷了。天气也烂透了。爸爸，我也喝酒。啤酒。百威。但我喝得不多。我也玩点毒品。我抽大麻烟。而且我有个很酷的烟锅。我会让你看看的，好吗？我和祖母谈过了。她说她会给你寄封信和一些钱。
Dad, I don't know if Cleav or Beth is coming down, but I'll talk to them and see. If not, it will be just me only.
爸爸，我不知道克里夫或贝丝是否会下去，但我会和他们谈谈看。如果不去，就只有我一个人。
Dad, you're going to rent a mobile home. That's cheap. $100 a week. That's cheap. Dad, try and see if there's any apartments for rent and let me know how much, OK? Dad, I'm going to take a Greyhound because it's cheap-- only $49-- but I'll call you ahead of time. Dad, all the money I'm saving from working at my job and my income tax check, I should have a lot, OK? With the money, we should be able to get a place for us, OK?
爸爸，你要租个移动房屋。那很便宜。每周100美元。那很便宜。爸爸，试着看看有没有公寓出租，告诉我多少钱，好吗？爸爸，我打算坐灰狗巴士，因为它很便宜——只要49美元——但我会提前给你打电话。爸爸，我从打工攒下的钱和所得税退款，我应该会攒很多，好吗？有了钱，我们应该能搞到住的地方，好吗？
Dad, I can't wait to come down there pretty soon."
爸爸，我等不及要很快下去了。”
Turn over.
翻面。
"Dad, I'm a cook, and I can cook us some [BLEEP] up. Cook some meals up for us, get a grill and cook on that. Also, I got a lot of CDs, like AC/DC, Led Zeppelin, Metallica, Pink Floyd, The Doors, Jimi Hendrix, Judas Priest, Black Sabbath, and all that. We can jam out and have lots of fun.
“爸爸，我是个厨师，我可以给我们做点烂东西吃。做点饭，弄个烤架烤着吃。另外，我有很多CD，像AC/DC，齐柏林飞艇，金属，平克·弗洛伊德，大门，吉米·亨德里克斯，犹大圣徒，黑色安息日，等等。我们可以一起玩，玩得很开心。
Davy Rothbart. You can go to his magazine's website, foundmagazine.com.
戴维·罗斯巴特。你可以访问他的杂志网站，foundmagazine.com。
Our program was produced today by Julie Snyder, Diane Cook, Todd Bachmann, me, with our other producers, Alex Blumberg, Wendy Dorr, and Starlee Kine. Production help from Katie O'Dunn. Engineering for our show in Boston by Miles Smith. In DC, Jonathan Cherry and Big Mo Recording. In Portland, John Frazy. In Chicago, Mary Gaffney. Our March guru, Jorge Just.
我们的节目今天由朱莉·斯奈德、黛安·库克、托德·巴克曼和我制作，我们的其他制片人还有亚历克斯·布隆伯格、温迪·多尔和斯塔莉·凯恩。凯蒂·奥丹提供了制作帮助。波士顿节目的工程由迈尔斯·史密斯负责。在华盛顿，由乔纳森·切里和Big Mo Recording负责。在波特兰，由约翰·弗雷齐负责。在芝加哥，由玛丽·加夫尼负责。我们的选曲大师是乔治·贾斯特。
Thanks to Adam Beckman. Ken Sleuter mixed one of our bands. Brand Cutsman the other. Thanks also to Robbie Willard. Thanks to the public radio stations who have been our hosts and presenters in the five cities. WBUR in Boston. WAMU, 88.5 FM in DC. Oregon Public Broadcasting in Portland. Colorado Public Radio in Denver. And Chicago Public Radio in our hometown.
感谢亚当·贝克曼。肯·斯卢特混音了我们的一支乐队。布兰德·卡茨曼混音了另一支。也感谢罗比·威拉德。感谢五个城市的公共广播电台作为我们的东道主和呈现方。波士顿的WBUR。华盛顿的WAMU 88.5 FM。波特兰的俄勒冈公共广播。丹佛的科罗拉多公共广播。以及我们家乡的芝加哥公共广播。
Special thanks today to our bands in all of our cities but DC. Dan Massey on drums, Alen Doughty on bass, Eric Muller on theremin, Nathan Swanson on violin and mandolin, plus Pat Brennan on piano and John Rice on guitar, and the great Jon Langford on guitar and vocals. In DC.
今天特别感谢我们所有城市的乐队，除了华盛顿。丹·梅西担任鼓手，艾伦·道蒂担任贝斯手，埃里克·穆勒担任特雷门琴手，内森·斯旺森担任小提琴和曼陀林手，加上帕特·布伦南担任钢琴，约翰·赖斯担任吉他，以及伟大的乔恩·兰福德担任吉他和主唱。在华盛顿。
OK Go is Damian Kulash on vocals, Tim Nordwind on bass, Andrew Duncan on guitar, Don Konopka on drums and Burleigh Seaver on keyboard.
OK Go乐队的成员有达米安·库拉什主唱，蒂姆·诺德温德贝斯，安德鲁·邓肯吉他，唐·科诺普卡鼓手，伯利·西弗键盘。
Our web site, www.thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
我们的网站，www.thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight by Mr. Torey Malatia, who begs, begs you,
WBEZ的管理由托雷·马拉蒂亚先生负责，他恳求，恳求你，
Quit tickling me. I have to make this an early night.
别挠我。我得早点睡。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助鸣谢]
You can download audio of our show at audible.com/thisamericanlife, where they have public radio programs, best selling books, even the New York Times, all at audible.com.
你可以在audible.com/thisamericanlife下载我们节目的音频，那里有公共广播节目、畅销书，甚至是《纽约时报》，都在audible.com。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共广播电台。